[Music]
okay well first of all I want to thank
you yeah for being here today for this
interview of course you prefer mr. the
gray or mr. the white I have both sets
of robes I go by both the names great
you won't follow me either you know
welcome I come back to you now with the
turn of the tide that's it's great okay
so I'm sure that you've heard about our
YouTube channel citizens and it's great
success on YouTube many of those words
have no meaning to me well maybe
middle-earth is a little further behind
a technology than I thought you know
what it's not that big of a deal it's
really not okay let's just dive into the
questions all right okay first of all
are you homosexual hmm that is an oddly
specific thing to ask you don't want to
start with something less personal
perhaps I will ask the questions around
here so are you gay no I'm not I'm sad
to say a powerful elf queen holds the
keys to my heart
Galadriel oh yes she's a total bitch mmm
ice queen is more like it dude but I
still want to see what's underneath
those robes don't you mmm that is truly
disgusting hmm all right so you're sure
you're not gay I'm sure yes never
experimented in college or on any of
your many all-male quests or all of your
questions going to be about my sexuality
yes hmm
Master human may inquire why you were so
fascinated on this subject well I wrote
this song it's about you and I want to
make a music video for it so I wanted to
get you to be in it but I need to be gay
to be in it well no you don't have to be
hmm probably make things easier if you
thought about asking Ian McKellen you
played me in the regular earth movies
yeah he's actually good well we wanted
to use the real thing but only the real
thing is actually good well no I mean
listen you don't have to be gay you
could just pretend to be good
it could be temporarily gay like an
Haitian mmm let me ask you this let's
say there's nothing but dudes left on
earth regular earth or Middle earth I
rip all the chicks are dead well
Galadriel can't die she can only go to
the undying lands you stop then she's
there alright we stop nitpicking my
scenario if the point is you're horny
you got a boner nothing but dudes would
you ever
mmm consider it open maybe no nope no no
no not at all even if you were in prison
no prison can hold me no prison can hold
may have only broken out of Prisons the
help of Eagles oh do any of that on your
own what time I have known you never
break out of a prison it's because the
Eagles are helping me well that doesn't
mean that you know everything listen do
you want be in the video earn some cash
or not if I say no will you still send
me back to middle-earth
not planning to send you back either way
oh how am I supposed to get back if I
know dude you're the wizard isn't there
like a wardrobe you can go walk through
or something that's non yet that's a
completely different fantasy series
completely well it's not completely
different okay
similar but I still I don't need to go
to Narnia you did go to middle-earth
well maybe you could take the Wardrobe
in Narnia and then catch a bus from
there there's no bus from Narnia to
middle-earth all right now are you gonna
tell me how to get home
how did you even get me here in the
first place all right all right how did
you get me here how am I here man if I
knew that I would be in this room hmm
well what am I supposed to do probably
recommend getting a job John
shelter all that cost money here in
regular mmm I know a job actually mmm
co-star of a music video I'm not going
to be in your music video I think on
thumb but now point me place to start
toward middle-earth and I'll be on my
way mmm now man I cannot believe you
made me hit him over the head relax
he'll be fine what are you gonna do when
he wakes up he will eventually come to
grips with the fact that he's stuck here
in our world and then you do the video
just so he can have some cash to pay for
some food I'm pretty sure this still
counts as kidnapping
you can't kidnap a fictional character